can I come to all of you and say by the
way this is one of the very rare days
where I wore a sheer shirt because
honestly it's cold for me I swear right
I normally wear a $19 t-shirt which by
the way interestingly is another form of
ego that's one of the best exercises is
to eat non expensive food to wear non
expensive things it's that through the
frugal tendency is actually a really
good way to yeah I I just came out of a
full month of fasting in Ramadan right
which is a religious practice but I
believe it's one of my favorite
practices of the year I practice so many
religious you know practices from all
different spiritual beliefs one of them
is one my is one of my favorites which
is Ramadan and Ramadan we fast from
sunrise to sunset so this year it was 19
hours of fasting no water no food for 30
full days it reminds you so the 31st day
when you wake up and have a coffee you
go like oh man that's amazing
yeah like seriously it's like it's just
a sip of water at noon it's like wow and
and the whole thing is that throughout
the months you start to go like so is
this what the people hundred and eighty
six million people around the world who
don't have access to clean waters this
how they feel man I'm so lucky right if
you know you start to remember what
hungry people actually feel you start to
really realize that all you really need
is a bowl of rice and maybe if you're
lucky a tomato and that actually is
quite okay quite okay right and we
forget you start to forget that all you
really need is a $19 t-shirt and by the
way maybe four of them if you're really
really doing overdoing it you might end
up with twenty does that mean you need
to be a billionaire how many $20
t-shirts can you borrow how many jeans
can you buy how many beds can you sleep
on and this isn't it's not just about me
you know I'm not criticizing the
material side of our life I'm just
saying this is one example of an
illusion
that we chase so hard we spent our
entire life trying to achieve it's never
satisfied